dimmelo in italiano di meno italiano
studi di animazione di walt disney
studios in azioni di walt disney loro
animano i film disney siamo inviati
speciali per disney ci hanno dato il
nostro passo
i miei questo questo sono io dopo che
faccio palestra te lo volevo dire è la
mia camera da glock questa è la mia
stessa camera zio ma giuro no in realtà
sta usando il telefono perché sono
importanti io con 5 milioni di iscritti
però in realtà telefono registra molto
meglio e cioè no ragazzi abbiamo anche
il cameraman oggi l'incredibile e un
maschio o una femmina e con the pin e il
pancino scusa ai campetti però me lo
ripago ma priva lui era sbarcato
dovremmo
siamo qui per darti spacca internet che
sarebbe sicuro dovremo fare più parti di
doppiaggio nel senso io mi trasformerò
in gianandrea non conoscete già andrà il
mio amico che doppia per ratti spa che
per la spacca internet cosa che andrò a
fare con sabrina che li frena
ecco di quali specie dei personaggi dj
di sabrina qualche figo che il basso da
dietro è così e poi vado avanti così ma
non me n'ero accorto di veramente venuta
un sacco fame super cosa sai dove
trovare della frutta aspetta c'è frutta
qua no frutta lì perché avremo bisogno
di frutta devo capire un secondo dove
della frutta sabri of a nissim a la
trovi dove l'hai trovata ma cavolo
era esattamente quello era beh vedo vedo
che non vedo che non lo sei
o mio dio va beh
[Musica]
in basso
allora insieme speak english
[Musica]
ciao ragazzi allora siamo arrivati a
roma io sabrina e lorenzo per
l'anteprima di ralph spacca internet e
la stanza che ci hanno riservato penso
che sia dell'albergo numero uno di roma
che quello di fianco a piazza del popolo
la stanza è così c'hai letto gigantesco
con la mia zaino comprato il
merchandising famiglia cioè tratto
queste l'albergo dove intervistato
spielberg quindi va bè signorina
francesca michelina ok mi sa che sono
entrato nella stanza della michielin ho
sbagliato ma comunque è strano perché
hanno confuso un po le cose visto che
qua c'è la lettera fa vj e la busta però
c'è anche quella della michielin che
ovviamente visto che sono un signore non
andrà leggere e mi hanno lasciato una
busta di wright spacca internet che
fighissima c'è già solo la busta è [ __ ]
vediamo sociali interni abbiamo da ralph
mamma mia che figo e gigante è fatto
benissimo ok altri ce l'abbiamo
allora abbiamo capito una sacca è una
sacca simas hd al molto bene e abbiamo
il poster
at goats rohm and friends abbiamo anche
la lettera indirizzata questa volta a me
incredibile hanno scritto anche famiglia
è giusto leggiamo carafa vj grazie di
essere qui con noi per la conferenza
stampa di wright spacca internet grazie
a voi il team disney italia è a tua
completa disposizione prendere questa
giornata indimenticabile
siamo felici di accoglierti nella
famiglia disney italia grazie grazie a
voi
[Musica]
allora c'è problema allora devi occupare
tutti i posti per mettere la roba ma
anche sei portato niente aspetto le luci
aspetto lui adesso noi stiamo e niente
non ci vediamo più
così non si vedono ciao bussano alla
porta
allora stavamo bloccando screen a quelli
che vedono questo che toglie loro non
vogliamo soccorre vogliamo sabrina
com'era il film il film era molto bello
abbiamo visto ieri sabrina
abbiamo due parti all'interno del film e
oggi ve lo dico abbiamo doppiato un film
della disney che era il spacca internet
e io faccio un personaggio che mi
rispecchia molto perché alle cuffie
dovrete indovinarlo come guardate il
film ma penso non sia difficile il mio
personaggio è molto più bello di quello
di sabrina e comunque sia adesso andiamo
a fare la differenza
la conferenza stampa con i giornalisti
che ci chiedono ci chiedono lorenzo
buongiorno il signor fa vj cosa ne pensa
del film che messaggi lanciato il film
che il film sia stato molto molto
interessante da vedere e da un piano la
sua esperienza di doppiaggio rispecchia
le sue aspettative
esistono i giornalisti con voci normali
dunque è stato veramente bello doppiano
film disney soprattutto ragazzi adesso
parlo seriamente
cioè ci ha fatto sognare un po tutti me
compreso ci stiamo a fare un bel lavoro
e secondo me è uscito veramente un gran
pezzo
e sapete perché per questo ma tu cos'è
che vuoi
quanti iscritti ai olga me perché ancora
dei semplici cambiati allora mi hanno
portato del purè di patate con dentro
dei pezzi di patata con sopra delle
chips sono sempre le patatine con dentro
una patatina fritta
io non so quante altre patate possano
esistere intanto prepara versione del
crimine ragazzi non so come rischio che
sta roba però ci sono delle patate
diverso di diverse categorie ma sono
patate amico mio
cin cin
la tua per rivolto al doppiaggio per un
film disney come è stata la tua
esperienza
la prima volta che blocchi un film
disney e anche se minima parte per me
una cosa incredibile perché comunque
disney fa parte della dell'infanzia di
tutti noi quindi è proprio un è stata
un'esperienza wow alla parte che sono
tutti molto professionali poi sentirmi
parte del progetto in qualche modo
veramente fantastico seraf spaccasse il
vostro internet come le prende rischi e
che cosa fareste ma se ralph spaccasse
il nostro internet in realtà basta che
non tocca al mio canale poi può spaccare
quello che vuole per quanto mi riguarda
allora se si potesse veramente entrare
in internet la prima cosa che farei
andrei subito a vedere chi è che si
occupa di aumentare diminuire la
velocità della linea internet perché ci
avrei due o tre paroline da dirgli c'è
un sito è un'app che secondo te ancora
non esistono e che vorresti esistessero
ci sono un sacco di acqua ormai al mondo
quindi non so bene quali app potrebbero
essere inventate se non ce n'è ancora
una che sistema i capelli beh quella
potrebbe essere ma andiamo a vedere la
scena un pochino di quello che succede
al trash e poi
trenta ore di gioco senza pausa ma
finalmente abbiamo trovato la mitica
auto di shank no non nina sto facendo i
compiti
ok come dicevo prendiamoci questo valido
no alle coppie due cose di grazia se
vuoi lo facciamo in due tempi
cioè facciamo prima no donnino
sufficiente compiti
no non mi la sto facendo i compiti
facendo ci deve fare dolci 11 13 non è
di ricatto e sabato sto facendo un bel
sto facendo i compiti sottacendo e conte
ok come dicevo prendiamoci questo bolide
molto molto carina senti ma visto che
sei così bravo che seguissi incrociata
ne vogliamo trovare una tutta intera hai
già perso schenk molto bravo mi fai uno
tanti piano se sei sicuro di voler
prolungare una o che non sono tutto
rinunciare il bastone è così che lo sai
fare sei bravissimo ora devo
ricominciare
dobbiamo stava bene era molto carina
allora allora dico inter ora faccio io
significa che ci ho messo devo di luca
lamma interconnesso per cui
interconnesso con va bene va bene la
somma riguarda l'acqua e con inter
concesso
ciao ragazzi in realtà spacca tutto
tornerà con rai brano tanto lo sapevo
potevano anche fare le lingue azioni non
era buona ciao ragazzi il ralph
ritornerà nelle sale con il suo magico
interconnesso mondo di internet e ci
saremo anche noi ve lo saprò
assolutamente sì ci vediamo a cena ci
vediamo lì
[Musica]